maybe you're trying to figure out how to
get started and move
fast on a specific business or
technology problem
or maybe you have a long list of
projects already in mind
but you need help prioritizing and
accelerating fortunately
ibm garage is here to help and our no
charge framing session
is a perfect first step in just a few
short hours
teams are able to rapidly brainstorm and
identify
their highest impact business
opportunities and define
plus a line around which are the highest
value ones
to immediately pursue this all happens
in a highly collaborative
facilitated virtual session that uses
enterprise design thinking principles
along with ibm garage methodology to
ensure incredibly successful outcomes
fast
let's explore just how we're able to do
all of that
through our ibm garage framing sessions
each framing session consists of roughly
five
to seven participants from your
organization including key stakeholders
from business
i.t and the like having a diverse range
of opinions
and perspectives from those key decision
makers really is essential at this stage
from our side we bring in an enterprise
design thinking facilitator
like myself and a garage solution
architect
along with the right team of subject
matter experts pick specifically for
your session
to ensure we can help identify
meaningful business opportunities
no matter your domain or industry
throughout this very engaging
interactive session we perform a number
of tailored activities
which act as a funnel allowing us to go
from brainstorming
all the possible opportunities we could
explore to prioritization of the ones
with the most potential business value
and finally aligning around and framing
that right
highest value impact business
opportunity to rapidly pursue
to make virtual collaboration truly a
breeze
we like to use an amazing online
whiteboarding tool
that allows everyone to generate and
modify content in real time
from creating sticky notes adding images
voting and so much more
there's something truly magical and
energizing about seeing that flurry of
cursers
hard at work as we swiftly populate
activities and drive towards incredible
outcomes together
in nearly no time at all we have rapid
alignment of key
stakeholders around exactly what we
should pursue and
the actionable next steps to drive
towards it kicking you off in your
journey
and giving you an incredible head start
all at no cost
best of all continuing that journey with
ibeam garage
is just as easy with garage you have
options like focus garage education to
jumpstart your teams
or you can dive right into things with
an ibm garage design thinking workshop
and minimum viable product build
enabling you to achieve your framed
priority project fast ibm garage is able
to bring an incredible
unparalleled experience a real
end-to-end partnership
and true speed to value success for
every project
all while partnering with you each step
of the way and enabling you on our best
in class methodology
visit ibm.com forward slash garage today
to learn more about ibm garage and
schedule your no charge framing session